I tell people my sister moved out west
their science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's all my
story before it was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
[Music]
and a lot of enemies
is called signed taskmaster he controls
the Red Room there manipulated fully
conscious but no choices
I should have come back for you how did
the others are there enough
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win of course for the best
but look into the past
okay you go to plan we shall I just
stayed up in coach my plan was to drive
us away where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
who you are
and me my choice
I'm done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch
I'm not slouching you're going to get
the back hunched listen to mother oh my
god alright enough all of you
it didn't say anything that's not fair